hello everyone this is amir from
audioscience review
this is a first video in what i hope to
be a series of videos
uh looking inside high resolution audio
from an objective and measurement point
of view and see what's going on in them
uh
high resolution audio is getting more
popular but there's a premium to
purchase the tracks and
uh would be nice to know for getting
something extra for the
money that we're spending so here i've
just picked an example um
music that i've purchased from the audio
company
name they actually have a high
resolution download service
and from one of my favorite artists
antonia
forcione as you can see in here
title is meet me in london and the
download sampling rate is 192 kilohertz
um what i'm going to do is
open the first track in adobe edition
i've already done that so we don't have
to wait for it
once we open that we see three different
displays in here
first one is an amplitude display so as
time goes by
showing us showing us how loud the music
is getting
we see uh plenty of black in here which
is what i like to see meaning
uh they have not tried to push the music
all the way to the maximum
um the they're staying below that
there's
air in there and so that means loudness
compression if used
is pretty mild i'm not going to talk
about this just yet this is a spectrum
splay display
i'm going to get you to look at this
side this is a is a fourier transform
of the time domain music samples what
that means is that it's telling us what
frequencies exist
inside that music and how loud they are
starts from zero hertz
and goes all the way up to half the
sampling rate
of 192 kilohertz which gives us 96 kilos
so let's go ahead and play a little bit
of this music and see what we have
so what we see if i zoom out a little
bit
uh and then
just bring the area of interest in focus
we see the music playing over here and
it goes up and down as it should
uh but then we see some other odd things
we see a
tone in here which is a problematic
uh let me stop it right there
uh this uh what i call idle tone or
beacon
is sitting here at around 45 kilohertz
it has nothing to do with the music is
what we call not correlate
correlated with the music and it's just
sitting there it's a pure tone
a single frequency uh what's the cause
of it
most likely it's a scan rate of the
monitor that they use
monitors start displaying one pixel from
this corner and scan the lines get all
the way to the bottom and to jump
up depending on the resolution they put
out a pure tone
and the analog the digital converter
being sensitive
has picked this up it could also be a
ultrasonic alarm in the building
or any of the other sources but
definitely it's not music what's not
music is also this other one over here
we have another one over here and one
that's pretty dangerously close to the
audible frequency band of
20 kilos so we have one over here at
around uh
22 killers or so none of this again is
music should not be there's
disappointing
now if we look in here this is also a
spectrum display
but it's sort of a heat map where colors
have been assigned to
amount of intensity at that frequency in
it
what we want to look at is this steady
state horizontal lines
if you look in here we've got one over
here one over here these exactly
correspond to these peaks that i've been
talking about this is the 45 kilos one
and we see it right over here this is a
25
22 kilos more boom is also sitting here
you also see a few other ones that go
actually within the audible band
don't want to be too critical of those
it's hard to examine what they are
but you know music is sort of random in
nature we want to see it to be
noise-like like this
we do not want to see correlated pure
tones that last the entire track
if they are that means they're just pure
frequencies
that are not music you wouldn't have
whistle playing the whole time
at exact one tone uh low band at low
frequencies
why have it at high frequencies so this
is just not acceptable
uh this is all total garbage it's gonna
potentially be amplified by your
amplifier and making it work harder
sometimes you can make some amplifiers
oscillate
and it could also drive your twitter and
cause intermodulation distortions
that actually can fall back to the
audible band
could have been easily caught the simple
analysis as you saw takes no time at all
every audio workstation's offer
has such a display and they should have
found and eliminated these sources
if they can't eliminate it then they
should have used a lower sampling rate
to not include them
no reason to have that speaking of
sample rate let's look at the spectrum
that was used
was the bandwidth used wisely we see
this sort of a waterfall drop of our
music over here
but then you know we see that it sort of
levels off
that's not natural it then it goes goes
down and
here it goes back up at half the roughly
half the sampling rate
this is clearly noise is probably caused
by noise shaping in an analog digital
converter
or something along the way it is not
natural it's not part of the music
this is pure nonsense pure garbage
and uh if we play the music we can
dynamically see
how much of the content is actually
correlated
together and that's likely our music
spectrum
so we see this obviously up to 20 some
kilohertz
is definitely music what's over here is
somewhat questionable
does not change with the content of
music
most of the time but if i play enough of
it
occasionally it sort of jumps up and
down in correlation with the lower
frequency like it just did
so at best i would say
you know useful spectrum goes to 48
kilos or so
which means a 96 kilo sampling would
have been plenty
it would have unfortunately still
included this garbage but
it would have eliminated all this so
what i downloaded half of it was garbage
half of it was good
i don't remember if name charged me more
for 192 kilos versus 96 kilo
sampling clear there was no reason to
get anything over 96
and you could actually go well below
that even 48 kilohertz and and would
have been plenty
so very disappointing paid extra
and what i was sold was was uh noise and
garbage
now they have another track that i
downloaded beside that one let me see if
i can find that
uh that one uh
is a 48 kilo sampling you also see the
inconsistency in naming
uh from that is one of my pet peeves the
other one they had put 192 killers in
the title
but this one does not um
but we can play that and quickly figure
it out so i've got that one downloaded
also
um here in audition
but right away we see a problem in the
amplitude domain these samples in here
are
definitely clipping or you know right at
clipping they've kept them just the hair
uh below disappointing the no reason to
max these things out
should have had a little bit more
headroom in here i can always turn up
the volume
if we play this and get it over here
and watch the view meters over here
you know this should have been you know
the comfortable range where this is in
orange
but look at this it goes right to uh
zero db uh we can do look at the
aperture statistics and see if it
actually has clip
but regardless it's just not good uh we
shouldn't have seen that
but uh let's go ahead and play the music
um
we see that the audition is smart enough
that
has stopped the uh at uh what looks to
be a 24 kilohertz
which tells me it's 48 kilo sampling
this is a
live recording and uh
almost invariably uh the sampling rate
of audio that goes with video
concerts is 48 killers so that makes
sense
as far as whether it's all good let's
play that
we see that all of it jumps up and down
correlated which is the message i was
trying to convey in the last one
uh so this is all you know up to the end
maybe
it's pretty good stuff um there's a bit
of garbage in here that i don't like
right here so we see another thing at 19
kilohertz
that's whaling you know levels pretty
decent minus 100
minus 75 db minus 73 db
should not be there uh and this is
smacking in
audible band uh but you know
due to masking because everything else
is loud it's not hurt
or the older person like me that's
listening to this that produced this
couldn't hear
18.2 or whatever this is 18 yeah 18.2
kilohertz
should not be there it's an artifact but
the rest
i should say this is actually reference
quality recording
but you know not doesn't have full
hygiene
much better bet than the uh 192 killers
at least we're not downloading a bunch
of noise and junk we're downloading real
music
and uh but then we have clipping in here
look at what's happening here
uh it's just not acceptable to have this
maxed out it should have been
should have had a little bit of headroom
anyway hopefully you found this
educational
as i mentioned i'll be producing more of
these uh
digging into uh you know other tracks
that i have and
you know it's like a reality show every
one of them is going to be different
thank you for tuning in and uh talk to
you later in the
future video bye-bye